we've heard the term drain the swamp a
lot and despite claiming to drain the
swamp Donald Trump has actually hired
endless bankers and finance industry
flunkies to his administration and it is
having a real impact fines on Wall
Street companies are down two-thirds
under Trump according to the news
corporation owned Wall Street Journal
quote Wall Street regulators have
imposed far lower penalties in the first
six months of donald trump's presidency
than they did during the first six
months of 2016 a comparable period in
the obama administration so far in the
first half of 2017 the SEC FINRA and
Commodity Futures Trading Commission
doled out 489 million dollars in fines
about a third of the 1.4 billion that
was levied in the first half of last
year if the current trend continues
we're looking at the lowest level of
fines against Wall Street firms since
2010 what's the significance of 2010 I
can't imagine why that would be a
relevant year in thinking about this all
the populist rhetoric from Trump was
always a sham I was super clear about
this there's a difference between
left-wing and right-wing populism
they're not the same thing
we interviewed professor Federico
Finkelstein about this some months ago
and I've been telling you the swamp is
being filled the swamp is not being
drained and we're seeing the result of
that the proof is in the pudding and
this is going to continue
we now have reports pat that Trump wants
to repeal the Volcker rule which was
designed to prevent risky trading and
betting that is damaging to the average
person and presents huge potential for
major financial rewards for Wall Street
firms will the middle class notice this
if they notice it will the committed
truncus even care this is one of those
areas where you know you got all the
headlines about all the crazy stuff that
Trump is doing and rightly so we need to
cover those stories but there's below
the surface this whole other underbelly
of legislative and regulatory stuff
things very important things as Trump
likes to say that are going on and they
are really bad for the average person
remember Trump said that Hillary Clinton
was owned by the big banks and that he
wouldn't let Wall Street get away with
murder and that was really just to play
to his base because I think a lot of
those people in rural areas across the
country may feel ripped off by these
financial institutions or Wall Street or
the stock market and they get to a point
where they see now Trump putting people
like Gary Cohn and Steve minuchin into
his cabinet and they can see that it's a
little bit easier for them to comprehend
why that would be bad but they're not
going to know the specifics in the weeds
of the Volcker Rule and all this other
stuff
Trump rhetoric when he ran is like you
said it's about oh it's going to be bad
for the hedge fund guys when I'm in
there they're not going to like me
the Wall Street bankers aren't going to
like me he'll be back for them he ran
against them and for the little guy and
not only are those banksters benefiting
they're kind of running the show right
as pat is talking about Steven venutian
and Gary Cohn Trump has hired a ton of
these people that supposedly weren't
going to like Donald Trump being
President of the United States and to
say that the administration has made
regulation sometimes they like the term
business friendly how business friendly
is an administration sort of a major
understatement and that if we need any
evidence that the entire drain the swamp
thing was a total farce fraud it's that
people have been saying Trump firing
people he hired is draining the swamp
when he fired
Anthony scaramouche II you actually had
some ideologically committed Trumpets
totally totally a dissonance cognitively
saying he said he would drain the swamp
and he's draining the swamp by getting
rid of the dead weight he was talking
about what Obama did or pre-existing
hires he wasn't talking about firing
people he hired because that means he's
draining the swamp he filled I mean it's
one of the weakest most blasted defenses
I've heard of Trump I don't think that
one counts I always fed sure to say that
and also it's not as if Donald Trump is
proposing legislation to try to get it
through Congress to eliminate some of
the some of the regulation on Wall
Street although he would love that he
would love that but that would be too
much work instead he's just trying to
abdicate
responsibility and not execute the fines
and penalties for malpractice in stock
market and of course underlying all this
is that executive actions when Obama did
them are very very bad but when it's
Donald Trump using executive actions to
circumvent or to avoid altogether having
to actually get legislation through
Congress hey he's just done doing really
bad things that other people did so you
can't criticize him for using the same
mechanism that he slammed Obama for
having used from 2010 to from 2009
rather to 2017